hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to um fend now unfund is a
love story about something hmm don't
like that at all
anyway we're gonna we're gonna remember
now I don't know what we're remembering
but something tells me we forgot it for
a reason and maybe we should just leave
well enough alone and go about our daily
lives oh boy Oh 2005 I was deep in my
World of Warcraft days in 2005 wait no
was I wasn't even out yet I can't even
remember now no no that's not right
I was in cities of here a city of heroes
that's when I was playing okay
what is this but put the seed I don't
know about that one I don't know about
no it's being filled with flea oh yes
the five basic food groups grades fruit
vegetables meat FLIR okay water the
plant oh no no I don't know what that is
over there oh did I get a battery or is
that chalk it needs batteries well I put
one in I'm supposed to do with the rest
of it oh this is bizarre oh I don't like
this Oh crystal emitting strange waves
many charged particles flared drink
what's clear to do fine batteries water
the plant bring the seed pour the floor
what's Flair the [ __ ] is Flair I mean
I've already identified what Flair is
but you know I just want to know what
you guys think FLIR is okay
all right then oh oh is this my home
maybe this looks like and there was a
game that I played a while back that I
really really loved it was pixelated in
almost this exact well it's a branch at
least I hope it's a branch it's a branch
armed monster oh okay yeah I can't
remember what it's called right now but
it was really good I'm wondering if this
is made by the same people okay
no I don't like that that's marginally
better moves Lobby slippers ooh
cop to use for flare oh I hope anyway
let's fill the cup up with water okay
maybe not that was good I got some water
in my cup I'm so happy about that fact
okay I guess I'm done here can i hey
there we go
is this the FLIR I've heard so much
about you can't go in here you can turn
on that light okay I think I got
everything that I need
I got batteries I can water the plant
now maybe I've got a box of seed and
then some FLIR dude oh wow wow what I
shouldn't drink it I really shouldn't
but I really need that fifth fruit group
Oh watered oh that's a little too green
I don't think a plant's supposed to do
that put the seed
any of this so-called seed that you're
talking about is there a seed around
here that I'm not seeing that for some
reason oh good its gate barred I can get
all radical and slide on out of here
yeah that's what the kids say right they
when they're skateboarding those like
we're gonna get all radical with our
FLIR we're gonna go Chuck some flare and
get radical our skateboards yeah fellow
kids is that what you say we say is that
what we say fellow kids
oh there it is it's you it's so not tiny
and impossible to see I have the seed
now and I shall put it on my device that
I built and I know what FLIR is time to
get radical oh that's not good like that
no that's probably that's that's why
it's not good things which I push the
button ah this button big button oh um
maybe we shouldn't be messing with the
interdimensional amoebas maybe that's a
maybe that's a big old no no
oh but oh no oh we said the power in the
kitchen might as well give myself a big
old glass of flair well no even I can't
limbo that low
I'm not radical enough oh all right
well hopefully nothing's gonna happen on
the way to the kitchen where would I is
this the Foos a box Oh mmm
Kurt uncle's whoa all better in this
neighborhood um hi oh I know I'm
hilarious but you don't need to laugh so
eagerly okay all right I'm here I will
return to you I will return you to
restore the cable the core module
battery the crystal we have time to talk
I don't wanna talk uh I don't want to
talk what did you do with my flare oh
you stole all my FLIR Oh
[Music]
okay I gotta go find zoom oh that wasn't
it oh alright a human or not a healing
Oh what are you hi
[Music]
all right I have nothing to say about
that I'm sure that that is fine and I am
fine and everything is fine what is that
is that painting always been like that
have I always had a weird mushroom on my
countertop thing just gonna turn that
bow okay all right well oh okay no
batteries in here that I can see
batteries in here maybe Oh Oh door open
Oh how helpful how not helpful clicky
clicky oh okay I don't trust this at all
there's definitely something bad
happening here I don't know want to know
what that rat tail is hmm oh it's a rope
rope here all right
nothing else nothing in the laundry why
did I get rope I don't know why I got
robot all right time oh that's not good
oh that's Oh
all right no no no it's some PT [ __ ]
up in here oh no no no don't be sniffing
me and I ain't got your FLIR well you go
get radical out of here oh that star oh
oh oh oh oh are you in my hair who you
and my precious beautiful hair what did
you do
I haven't actually tried the door well I
guess it what I told you no sniff
nothing don't you be sniffs Norfolk all
over me I know I smell really good
hey I don't know which way to look
about one of these gonna do for you this
on lockdown nope
okay well alright then people anymore
babies crawling around the ceiling huh
any more babies alright you know I don't
like those ceiling baby who oh well I
didn't find a goddamn dick diddly thing
that I needed except some rope and I
still got my slippers but I don't think
that's gonna help me alright can i reset
the power no ok alright time to go see
what new message is on the board yeah is
this supposed to be something I don't
think so I don't think that's anything
all right what do you got for me my
skateboard still there ok
oh the cable the cable
I don't even oh ok the cable is hey how
you doing how you doing buddy do you
remember me no you know what no I don't
I don't remember you at all but I want
to later and another time
Oh trust me I really want to know you
what's so wet and slips lapping over
here who's slip slapping my good oh
that's not good
I think I still got that baby in my hair
but that's alright I don't know about
that one
why does it sound like someone's
crunching bones in here whoa okay you
think I'd have some sort of internal
monologue about the strange is happening
in my own home but alas I do not think
your new you're gonna lock me in here
again is baby gonna crawl out of toilet
oh that's not good
that's not good at all oh that's not
good hey hey um my [ __ ] don't get my
Flair you stay the hell away from my
flare oh I don't think those are
supposed to be on the ceiling there's a
lot of things on the CI yeah ah [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] you know I don't like your habit of
putting my [ __ ] and babies on the
ceiling it's not good it's not nice our
guys all right something tells me that
ain't right okay all right what else you
got in store for me is the bathtub on
the ceiling - no okay all right then
well I guess I'll just mosey on back to
my home can i no all right well that's
locked so is there something in the the
new kitchen design that you think that I
should know about
oh the faucets on well that's obviously
the most incorrect thing in this place
miss save some water if there's one
thing I always keep in mind when my life
is in imminent peril is I was concerned
oh all right then
conserving power is also a very
intelligent thing to do
Oh Celie God why am I suddenly checking
the ceiling for ceiling babies you put
this fear and mate
um fender oh it's not oh that's that's
really not good
all right oh no not another ceiling baby
all right go okay well Oh Oh remember
remember remember remember remember
remember did you forget me apparently I
did you know apparently you think I
would have remembered some kind of
ethereal horror like this but you know
you know how it is I get busy busy with
life busy with forgetting wool oh that's
not good I don't like how there's a
forest of leaves in my living room not
my ideal still locked okay
why'd it get quiet I knew you were up to
something you dick oh okay all right
oh now I can read it clearly oh now it's
less threatening against my life thanks
for turning the lights back on no oh no
no no no turn these I liked it better
when it was quiet I'm gonna go hmm oh
good you've put my chairs back in their
proper places I'm so happy about that
hey battery well that's handy I hope I
only need one cuz god damn it this is
not pleasant
okay turn that on okay all right well I
got a battery I wish I didn't turn out
the light cuz I can't see [ __ ] okay well
there it is huh
Wow much better okay hello
you got my frill I'm Anita all right
Anita okay I'm battery connected I just
need some Flair
okay the core module and the crystal
well I'm halfway to insanity let's keep
moving huh all right oh hi well how are
you Anita hello how's it going fair fair
thee well okay well that's not right hmm
and I just wanted to pop a squat maybe
watch some Netflix with you but alas it
looks like okay you are taller than I
remember you being with longer arms I
don't like that at all very slender s
can you get out of my fridge hey that's
okay okay well I know I don't keep a
well-stocked fridge No is that a cat
what is it it's a cat oh no no no that's
not I don't remember buying that I have
no idea how that heart got it my friend
I was holding it for a friend friend
least I got this nice shapely carrot
sausage whose clothes that lets clue can
I close that nope okay that's open now I
don't know why that heart was meowing oh
that's not good
well Oh can't be any worse than anything
I've seen already so I guess I'm
mentally prepared for whatever dick 'try
you're gonna throw at me Oh
oh no I wasn't ready no I was not ready
give me a hammer give me a hammer blaze
oh okay do I still have time to get
radical out of here
my knee babies you know mini babies also
known as bugs oh that's that's not is
what I would go not good all right well
that's a problem
gonna have to call an exterminator for
that one it seems like there might be uh
might be something I need to take up
with landlord right well doesn't seem to
be too bad and it seems to have solved
itself okay heart OH or is that a
drawing of a boy I never know which okay
well so far so not bad oh no not today
is that a meat cleaver or something no
hi okay who are you don't you remember
me no I don't tell me who are you the
girl you ignored at school well alright
then at school
I've been beside you for 11 years what
do you want from me
you don't remember me at all at all
there were articles about me in
newspapers like I read newspapers come
on lady I always dreamed that you would
look my way I wanted you to pay
attention to me well you could have said
hi I mean if this is your way of saying
hi
very original uh nope nope no no no no
don't want it yeah about past part pass
hard hard pass frankly I think I
remember why I didn't look your way at
all
mmm well that's the problem okay well uh
must be Oh okay never mind then let me
just go ah what a wonderful day I want a
good nap nothing to worry about here oh
[ __ ] ah I would have been time to go
back into my workshop doodly doodly
doodly Doo oh boy oh man I'm hungry I'll
take I think I'll go get a snack for you
okay I'm just gonna go to the bathroom I
gotta wash my hands no time to get
myself a cup of coffe
no you stole my chair Oh box just for me
Oh
all for me that's all for me
oh you shouldn't have well this empty
like my own empty like my heart and my
soul mmm good time to take your nose
bath question mark oh yeah it's bath
time but I don't want to take that bath
bath don't look sugar some right let me
read about that bath Oh
okay
oh god what did you do that to me my
nose you broke my nose how'd you do that
huh why would you do that hmm let me put
my core module in there's a heart box
yah uh oh
come on don't futz with my Flair my fear
oh man I worked so hard on that flare
all right then
what else do you want from me mm-hmm
hello
I hear someone futzing with the radio in
there please don't I have it set to my
favorite station and I don't know how to
change it back all right then
am I supposed to go back in here no this
is still weird
alright that's still weird good to know
and now it's open now why is it open Wow
why singing detected whoa how will you
return to me how die what you think I
forgot how do you uh how die you need to
work on your grammar oh you went to
school for 11 years and this is the kind
of grammar you come up with some don't
add up
hmm okay turn that off okay never mind
you followed with my radio what I told
you not okay
some seems to be having with the colors
my eyes seem to be failing me in this
super darkness hmm Oh was Oh crystal oh
I've got Cristal got the crystal you got
here in my hand don't know what it is
kind of some weird moving [ __ ] okay
I guess we're just gonna well that's not
right
got some weird moving [ __ ] hair just
got up put ha right got some weird
moving [ __ ]
that's not right ok got some weird
mouthing [ __ ] time to put the
crystal back I guess ok did it I need to
launch it into the Sun do I need to
launch this whole [ __ ] into the Sun do I
need to do that because there will okay
I did it
FLIR go go FLIR go go go go go Flickr Oh
hmm okay am I supposed to step into that
hmm
again again with this [ __ ] you think
I forgot oh you still broke that on my
wall oh it's not good I don't have a
floor with my flashlight
oh no no no no no no
okay I'll do it I'll do it I'll do it Oh
it tingles how it feels weird ah oh
that's not good okay beautiful I love
Minecraft okay here we go
Oh 1996 so this was nine years ago okay
hello oh hi hello oh that was it
oh man it was so good oh so good that
was so good I love that that was so well
done ummph and great game love it love
it love it
ah terrifying terrifying very very scary
ah it's so good
humphhh end was delightful really really
it was honestly delightful I liked it a
lot and if you guys want to play for
yourself maybe there's something I
missed but I'm not a hundred percent
sure there could be anything that I
missed I'll put a link in the
description below other than that this
was a great game the developer did a
great job at this also the tasteful
nudes calendar is still on sale for only
24 more hours but good news you guys as
of this recording have already raised
over $200,000 to the Cancer Research
Institute through that calendar that is
an astonishing astonishing amount of
money and we're not even done with the
sale yet please if you haven't gotten a
calendar yet clicking the link in the
description below check it out for
yourself all the proceeds that I would
get go towards the Cancer Research
Institute I don't make a penny off of
this it's all for a great cause
and I'm not fully nude so it's it's
alright it's good anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everybody there's bought a calendar
already and thanks for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]